this is a shogoth
from hbo's lovecraft country but on set
it was a different story believe it or
not
these puppet heads and arms made the
monster scarier on screen
but that's not all from keeping the
monster's mouth open
to treating its anatomy like a weapon to
what kind of prosthetic head the
stand-ins would hold up on set
there were a lot of choices the
lovecraft team
had to make to make sure the show's
scariest monsters
terrified viewers warning spoilers ahead
for lovecraft country when h.p
lovecraft wrote about the shogoths and
at the mountains of madness
he called them indescribable not much to
go off of
so the lovecraft team brought in vfx
supervisor
grant walker and his team at frame store
to make the indescribable into something
tangibly scary
the vfx team worked off sketches
references
and concept art of the monster created
by frame store's art department
when grant received the concept art many
prominent features
of the shogoths were already established
for instance
that they had four limbs as well as
these tiny
t-rex like arms they did early animation
tests in a step called pre-visualization
to see how the monsters would look and
move in scenes
frame stores animators couldn't really
get into the cgi nitty gritty
until they had an idea of what the
shoghos would look like in the scenes
and they could do that thanks to these
stunt performers
stand-ins are necessary for both the
actors and
animators allowing something terrifying
to be on camera that isn't actually
there yet
they give the cast something to react to
whether they're being eaten alive or
just screaming their heads off
by leaping off a ledge and wrapping his
arms under this cop's armpits
this stand-in can show frame store where
to place the shogoth's
sharp arms that pierce straight through
the actor's
chest but it's not so easy to be
convincingly scary on set
especially with these big googly eyes
and missing teeth
when the actors first saw the show off i
think they got all their laughing out of
their system
so that they could perform on set and
the stand-ins make
frame stores job much easier by
identifying characteristics like
shadows which make them seem more
realistic
and it is important to be as precise as
possible
in this shot where a shogoth stands on
its hind legs in front of tick and letty
this stunt person had to hold this
prosthetic head about
nine feet high which is the height of
the black shogoth as estimated by grant
given the shogoth strength and speed
even the best stunt person
can't imitate every single move but they
do
help track the exact timing and space of
where the monster would be
allowing for a better and scarier cgi
performance
plus the actors will be looking directly
into its face
as opposed to accidentally looking up
into the sky
grant had many choices for how to
represent the monster's massive
size on set first he and the crew tried
to stack
two stand-ins on top of each other but
they found they could more easily
cast the same shadow by designing a
prosthetic head and arms
i took the initial model of the shogoth
and i took it in its
neutral pose and i chopped its body off
and i left its head where it was
and i left its arms where it was and i
figured out how they would hold them
to hold them in the approximate stance
of a shogoff
pose based on all fours and then stood
up on two legs and so i knew that if
there was a six foot stunt guy
you'd hold it up here now not every shot
had a stunt person in it
sometimes the monster was just too fast
for a stunt person to mimic
frame store was given both the shots
with the stand-ins and identical
versions of those shots with just the
backdrop
and no reference known as a clean plate
animators then had to place the cgi
showgoths into their scenes what a
stand-in couldn't communicate to grant
was how many
eyes to put on the monsters or how sharp
to make their teeth so it was up to
framestore to get creative with the
details
they made the shogoth skin translucent
so you can see
its entire inner structure if you shine
a light on it
since the shogoths live underground they
look to real animals that live in the
dark
after looking at naked mole rats and
deep sea fish
they saw their skin tended to be
somewhat see-through
this physical feature played into the
first episode storyline
when the characters shined a light on
the shogoths it not only
changed the appearance of the monster's
skin but also repelled them
but this presented a challenge as
see-through
skin is hard to render so they actually
chose not to make the skin
see-through until the compositing
process the final element when
everything comes together in animation
and because the skin was see-through
grant had to pay extra special attention
to its inner details
like veins or tiny bits of jaw that
connect
teeth to the mouth and the skull
normally those just serve a practical
purpose
but here they also had to look
anatomically correct
the shogoths weren't just covered in
skin
they had eyeballs everywhere
like the skin all 40 eyeballs needed to
look
sickly and diseased so they looked to
the animal kingdom
we didn't want the eyes to be beautiful
i never wanted to look deep into the
soul of a shove-off
we wanted to look at horrible dark eyes
like the black eyes of a shark
when designing a scary creature you have
to make sure the scary features still
function properly for example the white
shogoth featured in the first episode of
lovecraft
had black eyes grant was afraid that if
they were too black
the audience wouldn't know where the
shoguth monsters were looking at a given
moment
so instead of using the pupils to see
what direction it was looking in
the audience could instead follow the
surrounding skin
and this moving layer of mucousy
membrane
on top of its eye being a visual effects
artist
involves lots of experimentation this is
how framestore
landed on an important decision about
the shogoth keeping its mouth open
almost all the time early on grant
looked at what one of the shogoths would
look like with its mouth closed
it looked like the frog sure kermit is
okay for a temporary stand-in on set
but not a terrifying finished product so
they kept the mouth
open whenever they could the creature's
head is 80
mouth when it came to what's inside the
creature's mouth
grant made it scarier by turning to some
classic horror monsters that have
terrified him the tongue
was turned into a multi-pronged one
inspired by the
thing and he drew inspiration for the
sharp
fangs from pennywise and studied animal
predators for inspiration
we looked at sharks who've got many rows
of teeth like the top jaw
is not connected to the cranium and the
humanoid jaws connects to the cranium
whereas the sharks
protrude so you can actually turn the
teeth out it makes the really wide
stretching jaw the teeth start pointing
at what it's going to eat which
which is terrifying the mouth was filled
with 4
000 teeth which is no easy feat to
animate
as cgi teeth naturally want to start
intersecting when you put them together
this would ruin any frightening illusion
so framestore
used a specific rigging method that
according to grant
allowed them to nudge the teeth around
and keep them in the right place
part of what makes the monsters so scary
is that the vfx team
turned parts of their bodies into
weapons this decision
came from a conversation grant had with
lovecraft creator misha green
misha described it i think once as it's
a swiss army knife of weapons
and so every limb every point every part
of the anatomy
has to have a purpose and if you don't
see it use that purpose on screen
it kind of gets forgotten the teeth were
built for maximum bloodshed
originally grant said they tried to make
the teeth spin
but it pushed the limits of plausibility
instead
it was scarier to just make the teeth
clamp down
so fast that they could liquidize a
human head
now remember those tiny arms from early
designs
they were designed with sharp claws and
only really look like tiny arms
until they're used to cut right through
somebody you can also see in some early
designs that a shoghoth
tail looked more like a stub when
animators extended it
they also added a blade-like tip to it
but it wasn't just how the shogoths
looked that made them so scary
the right movement is key for making a
cgi creature truly
terrifying the shogoths are fast and
grant and his team had the freedom to
figure out
exactly how fast once again they looked
to the animal kingdom
grant and his team initially mimicked
the movement of gorillas
but gorillas are slower than what they
wanted so they looked to the cheetah but
that cat is too lean
so instead they based the movement off a
lion
a fast runner and a heavy predator grant
even matched the shogoth's run cycle
with a lion's average speed of 50 miles
per hour
even the smallest detail didn't go
overlooked
as the shogoths leap into action they
also leave behind puddles of
nasty drool it's got a huge mouth we
want to make it scary and disgusting
because it is so difficult to control
and there is so much of it
drool is one of the hardest elements to
recreate in cgi
so like hair water and clothes it needed
to be simulated which in 3d animation
just means a computer calculated how
something
in this case drool would realistically
behave in certain conditions
there also had to be multiple types of
drool for different scenarios
like drool running down the mouth drool
that stuck to its teeth
and drool that stuck on other surfaces
like the road
and nothing says gross and scary like
drool
filled with blood being an animator
doesn't mean you sit behind a computer
all day
to make this complicated shot of the
black shogoth
grant filmed himself acting like the
monster
one two three when we were figuring it
all out we knew it was a close proximity
to the cameras
grant practiced biting and shredding a
fake arm
then the stunt person replicated those
moves
and then they they add their extra
flourishing performance to it
were you convinced that was it